a new White House report on the chaotic
U.S withdrawal from Afghanistan in 2021
lays much of the blame on decisions made
during the Trump Administration you'll
remember scenes like these at Kabul
Airport the Biden Administration admits
there were flaws in the timing of the
evacuation Chief Foreign Affairs
correspondent and moderator have faced
the nation Margaret Brennan has more
Margaret good morning and good morning
to you Nate President Biden's decision
to pull the U.S out of Afghanistan led
to the collapse of its government its
military the death of 13 Americans and
it left tens of thousands of Afghans
hoping to escape girls over 12 can no
longer be educated it is one of the
darkest moments of the Biden presidency
to date
nearly two years after the chaotic end
to America's longest war the White House
admitted it should have started
evacuating earlier clearly we didn't get
things right here but the White House
took little responsibility for executing
a messy exit a 12-page summary of the
classified government reports claimed
President Biden repeatedly asked
military leaders if they required
additional support to mitigate threats
and was told no
and August 26 suicide attack outside
Kabul Airport killed 13 American Service
members I opened my eyes to Marines dead
or unconscious lying around me marine
sergeant Tyler Vargas Andrews survived
the attack and told Congress last month
that there was confusion on the ground
there was an inexcusable lack of
accountability and negligence
the 11 Marines one sailor
and one soldier that were murdered that
day have not been answered for the
hold CBS in September that he advised
President Biden against pulling out and
warned the U.S may now be vulnerable to
a future Terror threat I think we've got
certainly less than two or three percent
of the intelligence capability that we
had before we withdrew the White House
release argues that Trump
administrations deal with the Taliban
lacked detailed withdrawal plans and
blamed the former president's decision
to cut the number of troops there as
well as the Taliban strength with having
severely constrained Biden's choices
this summary is a snapshot of two
classified reports submitted Thursday to
Congress following a subpoena threat
from Republican Congressman Michael
McCall Foreign Affairs committee chair
we need to get answers and
accountability to the American people
the veterans and the Gold Star Mothers
we've got veterans that deserve a hell
of a lot more of the truth lance
corporal Jared Schmidt died in the
suicide bombing his father said the
12-page summary is an insult you're the
president of the United States the buck
stops with you it's your responsibility
stop making excuses
the long-delayed White House release
happened on the cusp of a holiday
weekend and there are no plans to make
public the classified details given to
Congress Nate
Margaret was there anything missing from
this summary yes notably absent and
internal State Department cable from
July that warned the Taliban was making
rapid territorial gains and recommending
that the evacuation be sped up and there
was also no mention of General
McKenzie's dissent nor any from the
military
Margaret thank you